even to this day and i just witnessed
this because i just came back from the
amish country in lancaster pennsylvania
and we went on an i we went on an amish
buggy ride and the
that we were sitting in the front row
and the guy who was a 55 year old amish
man who's been living on a farm in
lancaster pennsylvania colonial dutch
in pennsylvania dutch farm his whole
life and the amish if you don't know
anything about the amish
they don't use electricity they don't
use lights they only know their world
in pennsylvania they're farming they
still farm tobacco
in pennsylvania and we were on the tour
with a family from spain
actually they were actually from spain
and the spanish
uh guy the conquistador of the group he
asked the guy who
was at the reins of the uh buggy who by
the way was hitting on my mom in cecily
and my mom was giggling back
hitting on him and it was i thought
literally i thought my mom was just
going to be like i'm [ __ ] going to
live in lancaster pennsylvania because
make no mistake
even though my mom has got her [ __ ]
together the reason why chrissy d is a
little wild
my mom has got a part in that my mom
could get [ __ ] wild and move the
entire family the entire operation of
lancaster pennsylvania
and become full-blown [ __ ] amish
overnight that's no mistake that would
have been your step dad
abraham yeah abraham zechariah and yo
that guy smelled like pure horseshit
literally i thought it was the horse
[ __ ] but then i was like no it's this
guy's [ __ ] beard
yeah and anyway he asked the men from
the man from spain
yeah he said do they have horses in
spain and the man said
uh what do you mean like that do buggies
you know that do
this kind of thing and he said no do you
have the animal the horse in your
country
or is it just here and he doesn't know
anything and i said i said listen you
stupid [ __ ]
yeah no i said i said i didn't say
anything because i was dumbfounded but i
was like what do you
like he was so in a bubble that he
wasn't sure
if the animal he was on that actually
originated in spain i mean spanish
horses
that actually originated in spain was
only in pennsylvania
so if that's happening in 2018
with technology imagine what was
happening
in 1603 when you didn't know anything
you
basically knew keep in mind in 1603
and a lot of times before that and after
that just until recently do we know
people
you only knew the people in your village
and you very very very very rarely
ever went with more than 40 miles
outside of where you grew up so think
about where you are
and think about 40 miles in any
direction and that's all you would ever
see in your whole life yeah and you
would only know and befriend the people
in your village because chances are if
you walked into another village
they were gonna [ __ ] cut your head
off or tie you a stick for being a witch
be honest there's probably some kids
from ridgewood queens that's still the
story
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild